Michael Jordan the go because not only
did he have all the skills and the
physical traits but he's mentally more
imposing than anybody my goat is LeBron
LeBron hands now without a doubt Michael
Jordan because he never had to switch
teams
I can't I love running great but the
fact that he he had to go to Miami to
get those rings and Michael joy never
lost him father
I'm think about winning mother Jordan
never lost in the final please Lucy six
for six so I mean that's that's big-time
and he was making plays down the stretch
my goal is Kobe because he wins give me
the winner I go I would say Cadiz to go
he's so quick our Jane stop there LeBron
James because he's the greatest
all-around player no add like ever why
didn't nobody get close people who say
can write better Kobe better Kevin
Durant don't do none bear LeBron besides
shoot Kobe doing you're done better on
the side shoot so name a little bit crap
the heady guard just like me watching
him it gives me goose ball into his he's
cold-blooded let go it got to be Michael
Jordan everybody tried to see LeBron but
I think having to raise better to him
and I think Michael Jordan is just like
that my goal is LeBron James cuz he does
everything he shows the stat sheet and
he gets his team's to win he's a winner
if you put it if you let me sell it he's
a winner I'm not taking anything away
from LeBron but when they play going to
state and they came back with three one
Kyrie wasn't one related shot
I'm not saying the brown was in great
LeBron was great Kyrie was a no-show
Michael John was one of the attackers
you talk
LeBron day should be shot against gonna
sting I'm not taking anything away from
the brother please don't don't come in
I'm just saying
[Music]